foreign
[Music]
hey what are you doing here I have come
to help you
I don't want your help Rosalind I know
Ben and again I'm really really really
sorry but
we've got a boat
well actually
Dario
hello we'll get Romeo smuggle you both
to the docks and then under the cover of
Darkness you'll sail to safety before
anyone realizes that you're gone
that's um
very kind of you cousin
but I already have a plan
you do
okay that's
that's great
what is it I'm going to fake my own
death
sorry what it's simple there's this
potion that causes total body paralysis
for hours at a time I'll drink it
they'll find me it'll look like I'm dead
then they'll prepare me for burial
then once they leave I'll wake up
where a meal would then come out of
hiding he's at the Montague Chapel with
benvolia right now
then he'll find me in the church carry
me off into the sunset and we'll live
happily ever after
it's foolproof
okay Juliet
that is quite possibly the dumbest
[ __ ] thing I've ever heard in my life
are you kidding me there's like 50
different ways that that could go wrong
I mean what if the potion has side
effects
what if they actually bury you have you
thought of that what if Romeo thinks
you're really dead
I've I've sent Steve The Courier to tell
him Steve The Courier is an idiot you've
got to trust me my plan is better let's
go
Juliet
would
did you drink it already
[Music]